Public Sénat en partenariat avec
l'équipe vous présente sport etc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous je suis ravie de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
sport etc on va parler de tennis
d'arbitrage des remous dans le football
des risques de manifestation sur les
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 et de la
place des athlètes transgenres dans nos
compétitions internationales tout de
suite le sommaire
il y a 40 ans Yannick Noah s'imposer à
Roland-Garros il est à ce jour le
dernier joueur de tennis masculin
Français a remporté un Grand Chelem
pourquoi la victoire échappe-t-elle aux
Français depuis si longtemps comment
redonner espoir aux jeunes générations
d'inscrire leur nom au palmarès des plus
grands tournois du monde
et si l'avenir de l'arbitrage sportif
appartenait à l'intelligence
artificielle quelles sont les avantages
à remplacer l'homme par un ordinateur
sur les cours de tennis ou les terrains
de football quelle limite et quel danger
pour le sport
alors que la nouvelle session de vente
de billets pour les Jeux Olympiques
s'est ouverte jeudi quelle menace font
peser les suites de la mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites sur les
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024
[Musique]
pour m'accompagner aujourd'hui j'ai le
plaisir de recevoir
Stephen piennois vous êtes sénateur les
républicains de Maine-et-Loire et
vice-président de la commission culture
dont dépend le sport Jean-Baptiste reney
rédacteur en chef à l'équipe notre
partenaire Patrice agelaware entraîneur
de tennis et notamment l'entraîneur de
Yannick Noah lors de son sacre à
Roland-Garros en 1983 et Nelson Montfort
vous êtes journaliste à France
Télévisions et vous nous présentez
également votre dernier livre mémoire
olympique aux éditions Michel Lafont
bonjour à tous les quatre alors c'était
le 5 juin 1983 Yannick Noah remporté le
tournoi de Roland-Garros aujourd'hui la
question qui se pose n'est plus de
savoir si un français va remporter
Roland-Garros malheureusement la
question est y aura-t-il un français en
deuxième semaine comment en est-on
arrivé là c'est la fiche de sport etc
[Musique]
pour commencer petite séquence
romantique petit souvenir de cette belle
journée de juin 1983
et c'est Marcel Bernard le dernier
vainqueur français de Roland-Garros qui
remet le trophée et Nick Noah depuis
1946 aucun Français n'avait fait ce
geste
une immense joie pour le clan Noah
toutes les données de cette rencontre
étaient connues d'avance les deux hommes
se connaissent par cœur de façon de
jouer antinomique alors restez à savoir
qui allait imposer son jeu pour Noah
c'est l'attaque et la volée
[Applaudissements]
on a reconnu la voix de Lionel
Chamoulaud c'était au JT d'Antenne 2 à
l'époque Stéphane piénoir c'est un
souvenir qui est encore vivace dans
votre mémoire c'est un souvenir que tous
les Français ont gardé on chéri dans
leur cœur oui j'avais 13 ans à l'époque
et vous savez ça fait ça fait partie de
ces événements dont on se souvient on
sait exactement à quel endroit on était
j'étais chez mes grands-parents à
l'époque j'ai suivi ça c'est un dimanche
après-midi forcément et je oui j'ai ces
images en tête je pratiquais moi-même le
tennis et j'avais évidemment le maillot
de Yannick Noah sur les épaules j'ai un
grand fan c'est c'est un moment magique
qui entraîne d'ailleurs qui a qui a
entraîné des générations de gamins à
faire du tennis c'est aussi dans toutes
les fédérations on constate ça dès lors
que les résultats sont là les résultats
nationaux sont au rendez-vous et bien il
y a des tas de gamins qui se qui
s'engouffrent et qui se qui se voient
qui s'imaginent en Noah et McEnroe à
l'époque pour les pour mes deux plus
grandes idoles après pourquoi
aujourd'hui on a du mal à trouver ça
c'est vrai dans le cadre dans le cas de
Yannick Noah c'est vrai en tout cas
Patrice c'est toujours aussi vif
l'émotion quand on voit les images ça
fait 40 ans on peut se dire peut-être
qu'on s'habitue au plaisir non
[Rires]
à chaque fois que je vois ces images
l'émotion revient c'est j'ai des
souvenirs très très précis non non
seulement la balle de match bien sûr
mais après la balle de match il s'est
passé quelque chose d'absolument
incroyable tout le monde a en mémoire le
papa de Yannick qui saute sur le cours
Yannick qui couvert lui il s'embrasse le
public le public alors mais on voyait
plus les escaliers il y avait un monde
fou alors là le jour de sécurité on
oublie le public était en transe
vraiment et puis bien sûr pour un
entraîneur après avoir embrassé son père
et tout ça Yannick à couru vers notre
petite loge avec les gens de la
Fédération il y avait Jean-Paul lot qui
était là il y avait le médecin de
l'équipe de France il y avait le kiné et
tout ça et puis Yannick m'a attrapé m'a
fait tomber puis elle m'a serré dans les
bras et puis il m'a dit quelque chose
est pour l'entraîneur qui est très très
important quand il vous dit on a gagné
c'est
pas vrai c'est le joueur qui gagne bien
évidemment quand même mais c'était un
trait du caractère de Yannick de
partager ça c'est un moment qui est très
fort si vous voulez parce que oui vous
avez participé vous avez vous avez fait
travailler le l'athlète le champion bien
évidemment mais c'est lui qui écrit
l'histoire mais quand il vous dit on a
gagné pas besoin son petit sentiment de
fierté quelque part ça fait ça fait
vraiment du bien mais j'imagine c'était
la caractéristique de Yannick si vous
voulez qui voilà qui mais qu'est-ce qui
fait que cette année-là ça a été
possible ça a été possible parce que
Yannick était dans les meilleurs joueurs
du monde sur terre battu que dans les
semaines qui ont précédé Yannick avait
gagné deux tournois fait aussi la finale
d'un troisième il avait gagné le tournoi
de Madrid je le sentais je le sentais
très très bien et puis on avait mis en
place une organisation qui faisait en
sorte que Yannick pouvait rester très
très très
sur son tennis c'est-à-dire que
en plus du champion de tennis Yannick
était une vraie star à l'époque il y
avait pas beaucoup de de champion
dans cette époque là vous aviez Alain
Prost vous avez Bernard Hinault vous
aviez fini vous aviez Platini et tout ça
mais il y a pas beaucoup de monde en
sport quo on était pas très bon dans
cette qui gagne à l'époque
il était assez charismatique et puis
donc lui il avait pas besoin de coach
mental clairement
[Rires]
aimé bien ces moments-là Yannick il
jouait pour ces moments là si vous
voulez ces moments-là elle transcendait
et c'était je jouais bien évidemment là
dessus et puis je vous ai profité de
chaque seconde parce que c'était la
réalité on le sentais excité parce que
vraiment il voulait y aller dans cette
arène quoi c'était quelque chose avec le
public était absolument fabuleux ce
public qu'on a à Roland-Garros il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de de personnes qui
viennent à Roland-Garros qui sont des
licenciés et qui sont des gens qui
connaissent le tennis donc ils
encouragent mais ils sont en même temps
à respectueux des adversaires c'est pas
partout comme ça
peut-être préféré Nelson Roland Garros
cette cette capacité qu'avait Yannick
Noah comme le disait Patrice à se
transcendait cet aspect psychologique
est-ce que vous l'avez beaucoup retrouvé
chez d'autres francs
il y a d'autres sportifs qui qui vont
vous dire j'ai gagné
je pense qu'ils sont assez nombreux bien
sûr c'est un petit peu le contraire donc
je trouve ça je trouve ça très très
intéressant dans ton sens ça ne m'étonne
pas mais je dirais que quand on voit ces
images reviennent peut-être en tête et
en cœur une forme d'insouciance je ne
sais pas je trouve que j'avais coutume
de dire l'été commence à Roland-Garros
alors encore aujourd'hui peut-être mais
là il y avait une forme de commande
insouciance de de on est tout le monde
tout le monde était vraiment heureux et
je trouve que ça dépassé le cadre le
cadre du tennis mais vous parlez vous
parlez de cette insouciance on a le
sentiment qu'aujourd'hui quand tu
arrives Roland Garros les joueurs
français c'est pas le soleil qu'ils ont
au-dessus de la tête qui brille c'est
une chape de plomb est-ce que vous dites
parce qu'on a presque l'impression sans
trop s'ouvrir de ça que les joueurs
français aujourd'hui en France semblent
dépayser si j'ose cette expression parce
que bon là un peu moins ces derniers
temps mais jusqu'à présent il y a eu des
résultats positifs dans d'autres
tournois y compris dans les tournois de
terre battus prestigieux il y a eu des
des Français quart de finale demi-finale
un peu plus rarement mais
un Roland-Garros même c'est vrai que ça
s'arrête en général le vendredi ou le
samedi de la première semaine en tout
cas chez les garçons même un peu chez
les filles donc la victoire de Marie
Pierce l'a dit dernière victoire
française c'était 2000 en 2000 vous
rendez compte après
il faut préciser quelque chose parce que
c'est peut-être pas aussi simple qu'on
pourrait le penser il en parle
aujourd'hui assez clairement il dit
malgré cette capacité à se transcender
devant ce public il avait aussi
certaines peurs il les avoue aujourd'hui
et il disait moi quand je gagnais
j'étais peut-être beaucoup plus heureux
que le public mais quand je perdais
j'étais encore plus malheureux que et il
a fallu aussi
en quelque sorte éduquer ce public qui
n'était pas habitué à voir les Français
gagner et Patrice en parlera semble
beaucoup mieux que moi mais je crois
qu'à une de ces conquêtes une de ces
victoires en 83 c'est justement éduquer
le public et lui montrer qu'un Français
pouvait gagner et ça a été vraiment une
marche extrêmement importante à grève
pour lui alors je vais m'appuyer
justement sur la Une de l'équipe au
lendemain de cette victoire où l'équipe
titrée une étoile est née alors une
étoile si on pense à l'étoile du Berger
elle montre le chemin Patrice est-ce que
cette victoire de Yannick Noah a montré
le chemin en tout cas pour d'autres pour
le très haut niveau parce que si on
analyse un petit peu la situation de des
joueurs de tennis français actuel on a
énormément de de joueurs dans les 100
premiers mondiaux d'ailleurs je crois en
2000 on était la nation qui avait le
plus de joueurs représentés dans le top
100 et après il se passe quoi c'est
après Yannick il y a eu quand même
plusieurs générations de joueurs qui ont
été très très bons qui ont été dans le
top ten et comme le disait Nelson tout à
l'heure il y a eu des Français qui ont
été quand même demi finalistes quart de
quart de finaliser quand vous êtes demi
finaliste vous êtes médaille de bronze
oui bien sûr et quand vous êtes médaille
de bronze vous êtes reçus à l'Élysée
mais quand vous êtes demi finaliste
tournoi de tennis vous êtes rien du tout
pratiquement donc il faut pas se tromper
les générations notamment de Tsonga de
Gael Monfils et tout ça nous ont gagné
beaucoup de choses ils ont gagné
notamment des coupes d'avis ils ont
gagné des médailles aux Jeux olympiques
en double il y a eu des médailles
olympiques
Coupe Davis en double c'est quand on est
en équipe qu'on gagne oui mais il y a eu
aussi des victoires
de demi-finale parce que il s'est passé
quelque chose pour cette génération
prenant justement cette génération là il
y a eu
85% des victoires de Grand Chelem qui
ont été gagnés par trois hommes trois
monstres
Federer Nadal
et puis un autre aussi qui aimerait et
puis il y a Djokovic qui lui n'a pas
fini gagner encore et
quand vous avez des gens comme ça c'est
un peu comme un athlétisme vous avez
Usain Bolt d'accord vous courez derrière
une seule bonne vous dites pas de peau
quoi
vous avez été Btn donc directeur
technique national de la Fédération
Française de Tennis est-ce que si en
France j'entends très bien le côté
extrêmement particulier de ces de ces
immenses champion si en France il
existait un champion comme ça est-ce que
la Fédération Française de Tennis allait
moyens de le détecter ou est-ce que
l'encadrement national l'encadrement
fédéral quelque part bride certains
talents
non
c'est facile la critique vous savez on
est dans un pays où le sport national
c'est la critique
de partout et dans le sport vraiment
c'est la règle quand Yannick gagne on
voulait qu'il gagne toutes les semaines
oui bien sûr et quand il gagnait pas
toutes les semaines on commençait à
critiquer le joueur l'entraîneur c'est
tout le temps pareil donc on n'a jamais
fini des critiques là ils sont tombés
ces gars là dans cette génération mais
ils nous ont fait vraiment plaisir je
dirais quand on a l'habitude d'aller à
Roland-Garros et qu'on voit les matchs
qu'on fait ces gars la même contre
justement c'est Nadal contre ces
fédéraires et autres qu'ils ont battu
quelques fois dans les Grand Chelem et
puis notamment son gars qui a battu
cabattu Federer à Wimbledon il y a eu il
y a eu des grands grands matchs de
tennis qu'ils ont fait donc il faut pas
les rabaisser je crois qu'on a eu une
génération là qui était étonnante après
ça c'est un peu tassé ça c'est assez on
a eu quelques espoirs avec
cette époque noire et l’époque qu'on vit
aujourd'hui où c'est qu'on a vécu aussi
il y a quelque chose qui m'a rappelé on
mesure peut-être mal à quel point
Roland Garros c'était pour Yannick Noah
un rêve et la accomplissement d'une vie
en fait il le dit aujourd'hui très
clairement c'était Roland-Garros et rien
d'autre quoi donc pendant plusieurs
années il a vécu pour ça et je sais pas
si aujourd'hui il y a des joueurs
français pour le qui le feu brûle avec
autant de vivacité à fait à l'intérieur
c'était dans son dans ses rêves et
peut-être même dans un rêve imaginable
pour mon fils enfin des trois quatre
joueurs français dont on parle je
pensais lui qui a quand même qui était
quand même le plus près il avait un jeu
qui s'affin je pense que Patrice sera
d'accord en 2008 de mémoire il était en
demi-finale justement contre Federer où
il est battu de peu on dirait il a une
Nadal en finale ça c'est peut-être non
mais c'est vrai qu'entre demi finalistes
et finaliste il y a quand même déjà une
grande différence on se souvient un
petit peu plus quand même des des
finalistes
il marche sur l'eau quoi
il la contre-emploi il est quand même
sur Inter battu il a un jeu d'attaquant
il attaque beaucoup il marque quasiment
tous ces points à la volée enfin c'est à
contre emploi il gagne contre un
défenseur spécialiste de la terre battue
quelques années plus tard le compte est
en finale bien sûr et il rate sa finale
parce que il y a pas ce qu'il y a pas ce
petit plus qui a fait que noir était
complètement contre
totalement relâché tu es totalement joué
totalement sur tennis le compte a fait
une quinzaine exceptionnelle le joueur
de la finale il passe à travers il est
totalement inhibé par l'événement et
c'est juste ça et on retient on retient
la victoire de Noah on a presque oublié
la finale de le compte sur le même
terrain et pas forcément sur son terrain
de prédilection non plus pour enlever le
compte
c'est un cliché
qui qu'on a l'habitude de ressasser
année après année parce que
effectivement mais maintenant ça fait
quand même 40 ans ça n'a pas gagné
c'était intéressant vous disiez que
c'était un sport national pour les
Français de critiquer il y a quelqu'un
d'autre qui a mis son petit grain de sel
c'est l'ancienne entraîneur et l'oncle
Rafael Nadal Tony Nadal qui est déclaré
il y a quelques années la Fédération
Française a beaucoup plus d'argent que
la nôtres beaucoup plus de licenciés
aussi on parle environ d'un million de
licenciés le tennis est un sport
beaucoup plus populaire en France qu'en
Espagne et pourtant nous avons une
meilleure résultats une fédération sans
résultat doit se remettre en question on
dit donc c'est il y a les en football on
dirait les deux pieds décollés
tout à l'heure dans le top 100 par
contre c'est moins vrai ce qu'il raconte
pour les Espagnols qui sont des vrais
spécialistes de terre battus qui jouent
uniquement quasiment uniquement sur
terre battue c'est moi le cas en France
mais en termes de classement il y a
évidemment Nadal alkaraz aujourd'hui qui
qui prend la relève mais derrière c'est
quand même c'est quand même beaucoup
plus détaché on est il y a pas la même
densité que les Français après il y a
sur l'autre des lacunes dans le système
fédéral et qui font qu'aujourd'hui enfin
on a parfois reproché aux joueurs
français de de manquer la présence de
préparation mentale notamment de passer
ce confronter à la compétition dans les
jeunes années mais je crois qu'il faut
aussi accepter le la par un petit peu
aléatoire du sport c'est un les creux de
génération ça existe dans n'importe les
pays on voit l'Italie qui était à la
ramasse il y a quelques années qui
aujourd'hui a plusieurs joueurs dans le
top 15 et vous aussi être conscient je
pense que parfois la réussite en sport
c'est la rencontre entre un
entraîneur et un entraîné en fait je
pense que le duo Noah j'ai loueur
illustre bien on l'a vu dans d'autres
sports en natation par exemple voilà
parfois c'est une symbiose une alchimie
qui fait qu'on arrive à un résultat et
ça s'explique pas forcément par les
problèmes structurels
c'est exactement ce que ce qui vient
d'être expliqué regardez ce qui s'est
passé en Suède en Suède il y a eu
génération après génération vous aviez
vu Borg bien évidemment après ville
landais il y a eu tous on n'entend plus
parler des joueurs suédois vous avez aux
États-Unis il y a eu année après année
après et pourtant il y a 30 millions de
joueurs de tennis aux États-Unis
un titre absolument et
c'est par vague on s’aperçoit que c'est
par vague mais il y a aussi des fois
cette vague de joueurs exceptionnels qui
empêche les autres de gagner donc il y a
ce problème là on peut pas
systématiquement critiquer que ce soit
une fédération que ce soit une structure
ce qu'on peut dire qui c'est qui s'est
passé c'est qu'on a eu un joueur
exceptionnel qui était Yannick Noah qui
a été aussi qui a été vraiment tout
s'est bien passé dans ce dans cette dans
cette période là pas eu de blessure au
contraire on a moi j'avais très très
peur de la blessure parce que Yannick
c'était entraîné comme dingue comme un
dingue mais j'avais très peur de la
blessure à tel point que de les derniers
jours je faisais des entraînements je
lui envoyais des balles sur certains
exercices notamment pour smasher et puis
je faisais attention pour lui envoyer
des balles trop hautes et tout ça il
s'est lui qui me disait mais plus au
plus haut
attention c'est pas le moment de te
blesse donc c'est ça aussi c'était
quelqu'un d'absolument exceptionnel à ce
moment là alors on peut pas si si je
vous suis on peut pas savoir dans
combien de temps on aura à nouveau un
vainqueur parce que des champions on en
a un vainqueur de Grand Chelem c'est
autre chose oui il faut attendre je veux
dire on a aujourd'hui il se passe
quelque chose d'accord il y a quelques
jeunes qui sont intéressants mais on va
les laisser tranquille
vraiment beaucoup et voilà qui continue
à bosser comme ça tranquillement ils ont
la pression mais moi j'ai confiance ça
sera peut-être pas encore cette année
qu'on aura beaucoup de Français en
demi-finale peut-être pas mais mais je
me dis que Disney finalement
en deuxième semaine mais dans les années
qui viennent c'est très très possible
qu'on en est
après tout bien évidemment il y a un
domaine dans lequel la France Excel
c'est l'arbitrage à Roland-Garros cette
année il y aura environ 300 arbitres qui
seront impliqués jusqu'à quand veraton
des arbitres en chair et en os le long
des lignes de touche en tennis et
ailleurs c'est la prolongation de sport
etc
[Musique]
alors je vais m'appuyer sur le tennis
puisque dans les tournois ATP
l'association association of tennis
professionnel il faut tout bien
expliquer la fin
je parle sous le contrôle de Nelson
Monfort je peux pas faire mieux la fin
des juges de ligne a été officialisée
pour la saison 2025 donc place à
l'arbitrage électronique on en pense
quoi de cette avancée enfin je dis
avancer je sais pas s'il faut la
qualifier d'avancer
un avis personnel simplement j'ai pas
peur de ça je me dis aujourd'hui vous
savez quand vous avez joué quatre ou
cinq heures sur une sur une finale que
c'est une décision de l'arbitre qui va
décider de la victoire ou pas au
tie-break dans le cinquième set
s'il y a une erreur d'arbitrage à ce
moment là
c'est grave vous avez fait 7 matchs très
difficiles 15 jours tout ça il y a
beaucoup d'enjeux une erreur d'arbitrage
c'est pas impossible c'est arrivé il y
en a pas mal
je sais mais aujourd'hui il y a des
vraiment il y a des intérêts il y a
aussi il y a des moyens de contrôler ça
automatiquement millimètre près
aujourd'hui alors
c'est le cas sur les surfaces rapides du
sopen Open d'Australie
de ligne voilà bien sûr
au chômage cette histoire
est-ce qu'on perd pas quelque chose
enfin il sur un cours il y a des juges
de ligne excusez-moi si je trouve ça
chouette
il faut avancer avec la technologie je
me dis il faut on peut pas on peut pas
systématiquement
c'est pas facile d'être juste de ligne
on a même vécu une étoile où les joueurs
interpellé de ligne c'était marrant
comme tout tout le monde se marie devant
au bout de la logique il y a plus besoin
d'arbitre de chaise mais il faut que
quelqu'un qui qui
donne les informations quand même quoi
mais juste il a un lancera juste le
score il ne pourra jamais contredire la
machine c'est une mesure qui a notamment
été poussée par Novak Djokovic donc les
joueurs ils sont plutôt favorables et je
crois que c'est contrairement au foot il
y a quand même les sites les situations
sont quand même il y a pas beaucoup il y
a pas autant de situations en foot enfin
en tennis en foot en fait les gars en
fait c'est est-ce que la balle est bonne
est-ce que la balle est dedans donc je
pense que c'est
assez inéluctable finalement en tennis
d'autant que les solutions techniques
sont assez faciles à mettre en place ça
marche mon côté cartésien m'emmène à
dire que il y a des règles en fait
des sports avec des règles au football
il y a but quand le ballon a entièrement
franchit la ligne c'est comme ça c'est
c'est défini comme ça donc on a
aujourd'hui des outils qui ont progressé
qui ont énormément progressé qui disent
instantanément si oui ou non ça a
franchi la ligne même chose pour pour
les lits de de pour les juges de ligne
au tennis évidemment que de l'autre côté
l'humanité qui qui ressort d'un contact
entre un joueur et des juges de ligne
l'erreur parfois la communication enfin
tous en tête des des échanges de joueurs
qu'ils prenaient sur le ton de la
dérision pour une une
erreur manifeste d'arbitrage mais qui
pimentait aussi le match ça ça peut
manquer on est un peu dans l'air du du
résultat et aujourd'hui on retrouve bien
d'ailleurs Djokovic sur ce sur ce
terrain là
il y a des moyens techniques
cartésien comment on fait pour dire dans
les niveaux inférieurs aux arbitres
faites ce que vous pouvez faites le
mieux que vous pouvez de toute façon
vous allez voir arbitrer un grand
tournoi c'est ça par contre le côté
négatif c'est que ça va aussi
faire perdre un petit peu l'engagement
d'un certain nombre de d'arbitres de
juge arbitre dans les jeunes générations
qui qui peuvent rêver d'arbitrer des
matchs comme ça c'est vrai pour les
ramasseurs de balles qui on le voit dans
nos dans les clubs qui ont envie d'aller
à Roland-Garros c'est l'aboutissement
même chose pour les juges et là on peut
avoir une perte de motivation une perte
d'engagement pour est-ce que les
ramasseurs de balles seront bientôt
remplacés par des robots
dans l'intelligence artificielle parce
que il y a le danger et c'est déjà
arrivé c'était dans un match en Écosse
c'était en 2020 ou l'intelligence
artificielle a confondu il s'agissait
d'un ballon de foot a confondu le ballon
avec la tête d'un arbitre chauve c'est
pas une blague c'était vrai donc il faut
faire attention il faut faire un tout
petit peu attention justement
alors en plus on va imposer aux arbitres
qui sont encore là d'avoir des cheveux
on va on va rester sur le terrain des
sports collectifs je pense notamment au
rugby au football ou la technologie
tient de plus en plus de place on avait
commencé avec la goldine technologique
qui était vous le savez la montre de
l'arbitre qui vibre quand le ballon est
bien entré dans le dans le but il y a
l'assistance l'assistance vidéo
désormais on en est au ballon connecté
alors lors de la dernière Coupe du Monde
au Qatar le ballon connecté permettait
de prendre une décision semi-automatique
sur le sur le hors-jeu
ça y est on y est on est dans
l'intelligence artificielle qui va
arbitrer un match de foot non je pense
qu'on n'y est pas encore complètement
après c'est c'est ça me semble pas
illogique que le sport qui veut le foot
oui qui est le sport le plus universel
qui fait circuler le plus d'argent dans
la planète
soit celui où on expérimente le plus de
choses ou la technologie avance le plus
rapidement
après on l'a bien vu dans les derniers
matchs la part de l'arbitre humain
l'arbitre central et encore assez
importantes donc
l'intentionnalité de la faute enfin il y
a un moment où gardons quelque chose aux
êtres humains il y a encore une part
d'interprétation et heureusement sur les
sports de contact tu auras il y aura de
toute façon besoin d'un arbitre de champ
les fautes on juge si la faute est
dangereuse si ça mérite un carton tout
ça une intelligence artificielle ne peut
pas l'évaluer au tennis il y a pas de
contact c'est dedans ou dehors ce qui
est dommage c'est qu'on n'entendra pas
en fait l'explication parce que parfois
et c'est le cas au rugby je trouve ça
très pédagogique l'arbitre explique aux
joueurs et nous devant notre téléviseur
on peut l'entendre parce que ça a été
sonorisé la Fédération française de
football avait demandé la sonorisation
des arbitres pour la prochaine saison de
Ligue 1 et l'international Football
Association board ce qui organise les
lois du football ont refusé
on va y arriver on va y venir je pense
que comme souvent le rugby montre un peu
la voix dans ces choses là je suis
convaincu que le foot va suivre dans les
années qui viennent dans quelle division
parce que de ce que j'ai compris en
Ligue 1 donc en France de la VaR et de
ce dont nous parlons est autorisés en
Ligue 2 elle ne l'est pas alors il y a
des questions aussi il faut des
installations techniques pour
donc ça quelque part ça creuse peut-être
un fossé une des vous parliez de Michel
platine tout à l'heure c'était un des
arguments de Michel Platini qui disait
moi je veux pas d'un foot à 6 vitesses
quoi effectivement donc
c'était déjà le cas c'était déjà le cas
et on peut voilà là on a envie de pas
forcément la Ligue des Champions et la
Ligue 1 comme la Division d'Honneur oui
c'est comme ça c'est en fait en tout cas
vous parliez du rugby qui montre qui
montre la voie il y a peut-être plus
beaucoup de d'êtres humains qui est
arbitre mais en tout cas la bonne
nouvelle elle nous vient de la prochaine
Coupe du Monde qui aura lieu en France
la Coupe du monde de rugby parce que
pour la première fois il y aura une
femme qui officiera dans les matchs
masculins d'une Coupe du Monde c'est Joy
Neville et puis tant qu'on parle de des
femmes qui prennent la place non pas des
hommes mais des robots visiblement il y
a eu un trio d'arbitres féminin c'était
le week-end dernier au Japon c'était en
première ligue de football japonais donc
voilà je ne sais pas s'il est robots
vont prendre la place des des êtres
humains en tout cas les femmes font un
petit peu leur place et c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle on va continuer à parler
de football et on va se poser la
question où va le Paris Saint-Germain
c'est le carton rouge de sport etc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on n'a pas vraiment l'habitude de
voir Lionel Messi se plaindre des
décisions arbitrales et bizarrement on
l'a vu s'exprimer cette fois alors
c'était plus du tout en crampons et en
short c'était avec un costume assez
cocasse petit rappel de la situation
l'Argentin s'est rendu sans autorisation
sans l'autorisation de son club en
Arabie Saoudite pour une opération
professionnelle
promotionnelle pardon professionnel
aussi mes promotionnels alors qu'il
aurait dû être ce jour-là à
l'entraînement Kuru inédit du Paris
Saint-Germain qui a mis à pied son
joueur je vous laisse regarder quelques
instants de cette vidéo en images
[Musique]
moi j'avais plein de rendez-vous que
j'ai pas voulu annuler et je mais je
peux quand même être là aujourd'hui non
l'explication est assez drôle est-ce
qu'une faute avouée est à moitié
pardonnée un petit peu dans cette vidéo
il s'excuse donc auprès du club auprès
de ses coéquipiers mais pas auprès des
spectateurs pas auprès des supporters
pas auprès de je sais pas moi je pense
que si on fait une excuse comme ça c'est
tout d'abord vis-à-vis du public après
tout ce club vit par le public par ses
supporters ou du moins ce qu'il en reste
et non mais en tout cas
on va dire que ça lui a échappé mais
même se communiquer là je trouve tout
est maladroit dans cette histoire et
même se communiquer là dont on sent en
plus qu'il est un peu lu enfin Jacques
il est préparé à l'avance
on parle d'un immense champion c'est
Lionel Messi on n'a pas vu on a plus
besoin de le présenter les critiques
dont il a été victime est-ce que ça dit
quelque chose du public français
moi je ce qui se passe dans le dans le
monde du football me dépasse
complètement
je vous assure parce que je pense que on
a malgré l'équipe malgré toutes les
informations qui viennent de tous les
côtés est-ce qu'on a véritablement
vraiment le fond le fond des choses je
pense que non et en tout cas si vous
voulez
c'est intéressant je vis ça et je j'ai
l'impression que il se passe des choses
qui sont absolument incompréhensibles
pour le commun des des gens qui aiment
le foot quoi on regarde tout ça mais si
c'est un phénomène c'est incroyable et
autres mais on se dit
c'est anormal ce qui se passe quoi
comment c'est possible ce qui se passe
il y a des faits qui sont assez
contestables ce qui se passe pourquoi on
parle de cette vidéo et de Messi c'est
parce que il fait un voyage qui sent
l'autorisation de son club ça je
personne ni a commencé par lui de la
contester il est ensuite sanctionné
logiquement personne on devrait pas trop
s'en émouvoir à l'intérieur du club à
l'extérieur le problème c'est que le PSG
choisi de le sanctionner alors il n'a
pas sanctionné d'autres écarts depuis
des années voilà c'est un peu ça le
problème c'est un problème de cohérence
finalement ensuite est-ce que le public
français est trop sévère avec Messi je
sais pas mais je peux entendre que
certains supporters du
Paris-Saint-Germain depuis qu'il est
arrivé soit pas forcément ravi de son
investissement à tous les matchs quand
est-ce que Messi fait son fait ses
meilleures matchs c'est dans les mois
précédents la Coupe du monde parce que
un peu l'exemple en 83 il avait
rendez-vous avec la Coupe du monde
c'était l'histoire de sa vie voilà il a
il a tout réussi Messi tous ses rêves et
peut-être au-delà de ses rêves
pardon il en avait un dernier il a
préparé au PSG mais quelque part on se
dit à ce qu'il a encore cette même fin
quoi parce qu'on sait justement la
question que que se pose les supporters
quand on voit ce qui s'est passé que des
supporters alors ils sont pas allés
devant la maison de Lionel Messi puisque
de toute façon il est en Arabie Saoudite
ils sont allés devant la maison de
Neymar devant le domicile d'un joueur
pour manifester leur volonté pas
violemment bruyamment mais pas
violemment ils ont manifesté leur
volonté que ce joueur s'en aille
qu'est-ce que ça dit qu'est-ce que ça
donne comme image de comme image
sportive de la France elle est pas
terrible cette image pour Messi il faut
quand même pas oublier de rappeler qu'il
est venu au PSG à regret il a quitté son
club de coeur son club de toujours le
Barça qu'il est venu à Paris pour des
raisons financières du club de Barcelone
que depuis deux ans la première année il
a été quasiment transparent cette année
effectivement elle était brillant
jusqu'à la Coupe du Monde depuis il
marche sur le terrain c'est avec toutes
l'estime que j'ai pour ce pour ce joueur
phénoménal qui est Messi c'est quand
même vu l'investissement du club c'est
c'est désastreux pour Neymar
malheureusement il est victime de de ses
blessures à répétition et lui aussi
enfin c'est des c'est des joueurs qui
qui ont des beaucoup plus de bac de haut
quand ils sont bons on est à devant leur
prestation et puis la plupart du temps
on se dit mais qu'est-ce qu'ils font sur
le terrain il vaut mieux avoir des des
joueurs qui qui ont envie qui ont envie
de jouer de gagner des trophées là on a
l'impression que sont des ce sont des
joueurs qui ont tout Neymar était au
Barça aussi
qu'on avait de donner une image du sport
français
brillante elle est un peu ternie c'est
quoi la stratégie du PSG on parle
beaucoup de de d'argent mais
on a fait venir Galtier qui est très
semblablement le meilleur entraîneur de
France qui a fait des choses
extraordinaires avec tous les tous ces
clubs précédents on a fait entre la
français on l'amène ici pour pour serrer
un peu la liste qu'est-ce que vous
voulez faire avec des investividualités
comme ça qui s'autorisent à aller à
l'étranger alors qu'ils savent très bien
que ça n'est pas autorisé par le club de
jouer un match sur deux ou une mi-temps
sur deux enfin un moment donné on a
besoin de de gens qui ont envie de jouer
au football et de gagner des trophées
c'est plus le cas et la stratégie du PSG
ma maquette quand on parle
mieux pour remplacer
il y a une une image que je voulais vous
montrer parce qu'il y a un homme dont la
stratégie on la connaissait bien c'est
Jean-Michel Aulas il a quitté
l'Olympique de l'Olympique Lyonnais
après 36 ans dans son club est-ce que
c'était le plus grand président
bâtisseur français
rien que par la longévité c'est c'était
un monument du foot français et personne
y compris c'est plus fervent des
tracteurs ne conteste en fait la façon
dont il a construit ce club qu'il a mené
en gros de la division 2 avec un déficit
à une demi-finales de Ligue des
Champions quand même et à ce type de
champion de France d'affilée et il a
beaucoup aidé le football
j'aimerais bien savoir ce que
Jean-Michel Aulas pense du fait que
aujourd'hui encore nous sommes le 13 mai
et on ne sait toujours pas si la Coupe
du Monde Féminine sera diffusée sur une
télévision en France ce n'est pas un
caprice français puisque la situation
est la même en Angleterre en Espagne en
Allemagne et en Italie je pense qu'elles
sont diffusées cette cette cohérence je
peux pas imaginer un seul instant une
pression
une pression que cette cette compétition
maintenant le football féminin est
vraiment devenu majeur passionnant qui
intéresse vraiment largement il y a des
matchs en Angleterre qui font 40
000 spectateurs en plus les anglais sont
championne d'Europe voilà donc je suis
persuadé que cette Coupe du Monde sera
diffusée et je pense même sur une chaîne
en clair je pense il y a une
intervention de la de la ministre des
Sports améliaudet à Castera qui a
demandé aux autres ministres de l'Union
européenne de se réunir il y a une
réunion des ministres des sports c'est
lundi prochain une solution sera trouvée
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce qu'on
approche de la solution il y a en plus
une intervention politique qui est
peut-être pas forcément nécessaire je
l'ignore si probablement quand même
parce que c'est quand même c'est quand
même dans dans peu de temps finalement
donc la diffusion d'un événement majeur
comme ça ça se prépare il y a des moyens
techniques et
humain a à diligenté et il y a on a une
loi de en 86 on a une loi sur la
retransmission de ce qu'on appelle les
grands événements qui sont fixés par
décret 86 ça fait peut-être ça fait
bientôt 40 ans il y a 40 ans on parlait
pas beaucoup de sport féminin du foot
féminin quasiment pas du tout peut-être
qu'il y a moyen là de revoir les choses
et d'associer le sport féminin au sport
au sport masculin les les équipes de
France féminine sont performantes je
parle du rugby elle était à deux doigts
de gagner le tournoi des 6 nations elles
ont échoué face aux anglaises les
footballeuses ont été quatrième aux JO
on fait une demi-finale à l'euro
et dans d'autres disciplines encore donc
je pense que aujourd'hui il y a moyen
d'associer on parlait du tennis tout à
l'heure mais on a oublié de citer que on
a de formidables joueuses françaises
Mauresmo qui a été numéro 1 mondial qui
a gagné deux tournois du Grand Chelem
Caroline Garcia aujourd'hui donc c'est
une question d'équilibre d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui les prix à Roland-Garros
sont équivalents homme et femme c'est
loin d'être le cas pour le foot par
exemple en droit de retransmission on a
un rapport de 1 à 500 sur les droits
annuels de télévision donc là il y a
quelque chose à faire et donc sur le
réglementaire c'est trop tard sans doute
pour la Coupe du Monde 2023 mais
probablement qu'il faut regarder ce que
le décret fixe comme grands événements
sportifs obligatoires à diffuser en
clair pour l'accès du grand public parce
que pour les chaînes privées et pour les
plateformes parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
la concurrence des plateformes qui
diffusent et les chaînes publiques
Nelson Monfort est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est une responsabilité je vais
être un petit peu dur mais est-ce que
c'est une responsabilité si personne ne
doit diffuser cette Coupe du Monde
Féminine est-ce que c'est une
responsabilité du service nous je pense
pas qu'on puisse nous faire le reproche
je vais tout simplement vous citer un
exemple un le sport féminin est vraiment
à égalité au casier égalité en tout cas
alors évidemment le rugby etc
idem d'ailleurs pour le sport handicapé
ça je tiens à le dire nous nous allons
je développe je sors un peu de
l'agression mais petit digression oui
mais nous allons diffuser en intégralité
les Jeux paralympiques en intégralité
donc je pense que si on diffuse en
intégralité les Jeux paralympiques je
pense qu'on trouvera une solution je dis
pas nous nécessairement mais je suis
intimement persuadé qu'entre TF1 M6 et
autres cette compétition sera diffusée
si je l'avais je vous la donnerai il
nous est arrivé assez souvent de venir
comment dire à la rescousse si je puis
dire d'un événement je pense notamment
au handball handball féminin etc en
balle féminin tiens justement voilà dans
les baskets etc nous nous sommes des des
nous et en particulier je suis le plus
ardent défenseur si toutefois le sport
féminin doit être défendu pour une
égalité une parité totale la seule chose
c'est qu'effectivement comme avec cette
question Alessandro concernant Roland
Garros effectivement l'établit la
programmation à égalité la chose est
évidemment par définition les matchs
masculins durs plus longtemps sauf ceux
de Nadal enfin en général durant un peu
plus loin donc au total d'heure
évidemment il y a un peu plus oui mais
sur la programmation nous sommes très
très attentifs vous parliez des Jeux
paralympiques avant de parler de jeux
olympiques on va le faire dans quelques
instants une image n'a pas trouvé de
diffuseur officiel sur sur les
télévisions du monde mais elle a été
largement reprise par les réseaux
sociaux et nous tenions à vous la
présenter samedi 6 mai des iraniennes
ont pris le départ du semi-marathon de
Shiraz certaines d'entre elles bravant
la police religieuse se sont élancées
sans voile conséquences le président de
la Fédération iranienne d'athlétisme du
remettre sa démission mais le courage
des iraniennes qui depuis le début de la
révolte en septembre dernier font preuve
d'un courage inouïe sont éblouissante
elle force notre admiration et nous
tenions à vous montrer cette image de
ces femmes lors de ce semi-marathon une
Iranienne justement Annie rostamian
championne de tir figure parmi les
premiers qualifiés pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris 2024 mais la
question qui se pose en France n'est pas
de savoir si agnier rostamanian pourra
venir mais c'est de savoir si la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites peut faire peser un risque sur
les Jeux Olympiques et c'est la
confrontation de sport etc
[Musique]
lors des dernières manifestations
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites des slogans menaçant la bonne
tenue des Jeux Olympiques se sont
multipliées avec notamment le pas de
retrait pas de Jo le secrétaire général
de la CFDT Laurent Berger s'est dit
opposé très fermement à cette menace en
l'écoute les JO ça doit être une fête ça
doit être une fête ça doit être un
moment un moment magique pour ceux qui
aiment le sport et donc il est hors de
question de faire ni ce style de menace
ni ce style d'action pendant les JO je
pense pas que ce serait vous savez le
syndicalisme il a quand même une image
qui a été redorée dans cette période il
a assumé sa part de responsabilité il a
dit on a dit les choses franchement
parfois un peu vertement on n'a jamais
passé la ligne jaune jamais donc on
ressort plutôt grandi de cette situation
de cette de cette période moi je suis
pas pourquoi on embête le bon
fonctionnement des JO
donc la CFDT non bettera pas le bon
fonctionnement des JO mais est-ce que
c'est un risque qui existe et qu'on doit
prendre au sérieux c'est encore un peu
loin on est à plus d'un an de
d'ouverture des Jeux Olympiques je
n'imagine pas qu'on puisse gâcher une
telle fête comme ça une telle fête
mondiale c'est l'événement mondial par
définition sur notre planète on a la
chance de l'accueillir 100 ans après
l'édition de 1924 en France
il faut arrêter les bêtises à un moment
donné je crois que il faut il faut
préserver ça ok il y a des
revendications
l'épisode des retraites et Laurent
Berger l'a dit le syndicalisme a joué
son rôle maintenant les choses sont
aussi actées de ce côté là il faut il
faut que le film s'arrête à un moment
donné mais pourtant une action concrète
enfin des actions concrètes contre des
événements sportifs ça existe et il y a
pas longtemps lors d'un match de Pro D2
de rugby entre Agen et 9h coup pire de
courant revendiquer par la CGT voilà on
coupe tout donc c'est possible alors je
comprends que les Jeux Olympiques se
soient moins mais en tout cas c'est
quelque c'est une possibilité là
lumière du Stade de France pour 100
mètres
de fou il y a des groupes électrogènes
qui sont qui sont prévus pour des
événements comme ça dont on sait qu'ils
peuvent être la cible d'actions
violentes parce que j'estime que c'est
une forme de violence sociale en compte
de ceux qui viennent dans les stats qui
payent leur place etc il faut aussi que
les organisations syndicales qui qui
cautionnent ça soit responsabilisé face
aux actes qu'ils cautionneraient il y a
une responsabilité à portée et je crois
que là il faudra il faudra engager
toutes les poursuites si tel est le tel
cas en tout cas envers ceux qui qui
cautionnent ce genre de d'action ça je
pense qu'il faut s'attendre
effectivement à ce que les
contestataires se servent des des jeux
comme une vitrine en même temps la loi
géo qui a été
voter elle donne pas envie de
dire tout le monde et même nous on sera
sous étroite de surveillance à ce
moment-là et peut-être même après mais
ça c'est un autre sujet mais voilà je
crois qu'il les jeux ça a toujours été
une vitrine on peut pas considérer le
sport comme une bulle hors de la société
on est le sport évolue dans une société
avec les cours pourtant j'ai entendu
quelques mois c'est absolument
inévitable voilà c'est la pollinisation
des jeux c'est vieux comme les jeux je
pars faire l'histoire mais de des jeux
de 36 à Berlin jusqu'au boycott des
années 80 en passant par Munich en 72 et
le drame que ça a été évidemment
pas sur le même plan vous vous doutez
bien mais au courant pour manifester
contre une réforme il faut bien être
conscient de ça que voilà quel que soit
les causes qu'elle soit louable ou
beaucoup moins louable les gens s'en
servent comme une vitrine alors il y a
un autre risque qui existe c'est celui
des faux volontaires alors ces
volontaires qui se sont inscrits qui
participeront à l'organisation des Jeux
olympiques mais qui ont décidé de
perturber les jeux ou de pas venir
c'est quand même terrible ça c'est quand
même terrible c'est sûr sur l'évolution
de notre société que convienne penser à
ça et je trouve ça c'est affreux quoi
quelque part
si on veut perturber une organisation
s'inscrire dire qu'on sera là et pas
venir aux derniers moments
45000 bénévoles mais il y avait 300000
candidatures donc j'imagine que s'il y a
une défection on pourra appeler le
c'est très
intéressant si vous voulez être
volontaire pour les jeux
c'est ça c'est terminé en début de
semaine dernière on a besoin de 45000
volontaires 300 000 en déposé leur
dossier ce sont des dossiers qui
arrivent du monde entier il y a très peu
très il y a beaucoup pardon il y a un
tiers de dossier qui viennent de jeunes
de moins de 25 ans donc c'est plutôt une
place réservée aux jeunes on pense à un
bénévolat festif
sauf qu'on c'est du bénévolat vraiment
il y a un débat là-dessus c'est que être
bénévole au jeu c'est absolument pas une
signature c'est c'est quelque chose qui
peut être parfois fatigant et je peux
concevoir que certains ces meufs que ce
soit des tâches qui soit absolument pas
rémunérés et pour certaines même pas
d'effrayer donc voilà peut-être qu'un
jour faudra réfléchir à
on parle on parle d'héritage de des jeux
de paris 2024 notamment pour la
Seine-Saint-Denis ou beaucoup de choses
vont se passer on pouvait pas trouver
des excusez-moi d'être un peu trivial
mais des jobs rémunérés pour les jeunes
de la Seine-Saint-Denis
pour moi la question c'est pour ça je
suis allé visiter le village olympique
c'est vraiment chouette et ça transforme
on voit que c'est aussi une opportunité
extraordinaire pour la Seine-Saint-Denis
de se transformer dans un département
qu'on a tellement besoin donc ça c'est
le premier point ensuite pour les
bénévoles enfin quel meilleur action que
de donner un peu de son temps même si ça
occasionne quelques frais personnels
pour un événement de ce type là enfin je
trouve que si on si on rémunère toute
action tout engagement ben on sabre
justement la nature même de l'engagement
les Jeux Olympiques nous n'en verrons
qu'une édition probablement c'est un
souvenir absolument et c'est une
expérience personnelle qui doit
transcender tout et toutes les au-delà
de votre esprit cartésien vous avez
aussi un esprit romantique en tout cas
une vision romantique des Jeux
Olympiques une pensée pour Bernard
lapassée qui était à l'origine de Paris
2024 sans lui il n'y aurait pas les jeux
à Paris il était le co-président du
comité de candidature il nous a quitté
il y a quelques jours c'était un homme
extraordinaire qui a fait beaucoup pour
le sport français et le rayonnement du
sport français dans le monde si vous
permettez une pensée je sais que vous
devez en tout cas chez vous ça vous
touchera parce que vous le connaissiez
bien pour Jean-Marc pochard photographe
de l'équipe et quand on a vu assez
brièvement la photo une étoile est née
c'était il me semble que c'est Jean-Marc
Pochet qui nous a quitté il y a il y a
quelques jours MERCI MERCI BEAUCOUP
Nelson dernier thème de cette émission
quelle place donner aux athlètes
transgenres dans le sport de haut niveau
c'est la performance de sport etc
[Musique]
le domaine dernier Austin qui Lipps
devenait la première athlète transgenre
a remporté une course cycliste à étape
lors du tour du Gila aux États-Unis il y
a un mois à la jeune athlète transgenre
française faisait la Une de l'équipe
magazine pour dénoncer la décision du 23
mars dernier de World of latex la
Fédération internationale de
l'athlétisme on va dire résumer ça comme
ça la World Of Light x interdisait les
athlètes transgenres dans les épreuves
d'athlétisme un an des Jeux Olympiques à
Paris on doit réserver quelle place aux
athlètes transgenres je sais que c'est
une question compliquée c'est une
question difficile je pense pas que ça
se dénoue avant les Jeux olympiques de
2024 probablement que aujourd'hui on
voit bien que les fédérations chaque
fédération réfléchies aux problèmes et
on est sur du cas par cas aujourd'hui
donc je trouve que c'est la bonne
démarche parce que il y a probablement
des sports où il y a pas de sujets on
parlait tout à l'heure de l'équitation
on a des hommes et des femmes qui des
cavaliers qui sont homme ou femme ça
sans aucune aucun problème dans les dans
les cross internationaux ou autre
évidemment sur d'autres disciplines sur
le vélo enfin tout ce qui est fait appel
à davantage de puissance physique
évidemment il y a un sujet il peut y a
même on peut même envisager enfin des
motivations des des sportives qui disent
bon écoutez si nous demain on est
dépassé par
d'anciens on cyclisme
l'ancienne cycliste française marin
Clinet
a déposer un dossier auprès de l'UCI
l'Union Cycliste Internationale
expliquant que 90% des cyclistes femmes
étaient contre la présence d'athlètes
transgenres dans le peloton à l'inverse
quelle place on réserve à des personnes
qui ont choisi de changer de sexe voilà
parce que c'est comme des choix de vie
extrêmement lourds évidemment donc la
question est extrêmement compliquée à
trancher et je suis pas sûr que le fait
que chaque fédération édicte ses propres
règles soient forcément
la seule fois le le signe d'une solution
chauffant n'est face à un vrai dilemme
qui était quand je disais tout à l'heure
que le sport était pas en dehors de la
société bah c'est encore une nouvelle
illustration on avait la question de
l'identité se posait pas forcément c'est
terminé il y a souvent 20 ans même si on
a eu des exemples dans d'autres sports
et notamment de tennis mais oui j'avoue
que je suis très très perplexe enfin
c'est la question peut amener à une
convergence
fruits des expériences des défédérations
du travail des fédérations à une
convergence pour une définition globale
notamment de testostérone et taux de
testostérone à ne pas dépasser peut-être
que ça peut être une voix pour
effectivement préserver une certaine
dictée parce que c'est comme aussi de ça
qu'il s'agit dans le tennis la question
se pose également la question s'est
posée déjà dans les années 70 dans les
années 70 il y a eu un vrai un vrai
problème si vous voulez il y a une femme
qui avait plus de 40 ans qui s'est mis à
gagner soudainement des tournois de
tennis René Richard il s'est mis à
gagner des tourn sur le circuit WTA et
c'était une personne qui était voilà
très puissante qui avait un gros service
une très bonne volée et tout ça puis
elle était troublante son physique était
troublante et il y a une enquête qui a
été faite et finalement cette teckel
cette enquête a montré que cette femme
avait été opérée au Maroc et que c'était
précédemment
un homme et que c'était un médecin
ophtalmologiste très connu qui avait été
un niveau correct mais moyen au niveau
masculin et puis après son opération
elle a ses mises à gagner dans ces
tournois WTA et là ça a été intolé
général parce que évidemment toutes les
compétitrices à ce moment-là ce sont
révoltés
la fédération américaine la suspendue
elle a fait un procès et puis c'est le
tribunal en tribunal américain à New
York qui finalement la rétablit elle a
pu jouer et elle est devenue 20e
mondiale avec des joueuses qui voulaient
pas jouer contre elle enfin ça a fait ça
fait vraiment c'était ça a duré pendant
des années et elle est devenue très très
populaire elle faisait la une de tous
les jours non enfin c'était quelque
chose d'assez d'assez incroyable c'est
un vrai souci quand dans le sport vous
avez cette différence entre l'homme et
les femmes la question c'est l'inclusion
ou l'équité j'ai l'impression qu'il
comme s'il fallait choisir entre deux
choses qui quelque part tiennent à cœur
à tous les gens qui aiment le sport
ça pose des questions qu'on ne se posait
pas il y a quelques années alors c'est
c'est très marginal je sais pas quelle
proportion des sportifs ça peut
représenter mais c'est vraiment très
très peu de cas en fait à examiner dans
le monde professionnel dans le monde
amateur dans le monde amateur la
question se pose sans doute moins et int
un transgenre dans une équipe de foot en
équipe de rugby je pense que ça ça dans
les sports individuels c'est c'est plus
compliqué le cyclisme le tennis là la
différence par exemple c'est c'est
prononcer de façon très claire contre la
présence des athlètes
défenseur de la cause féminine au
premier plan voilà c'est un témoignage
très très intéressant donc
ça démonte toute la complicité de la
question on voit bien que le monde du
sport est extrêmement divisé et là où
avant effectivement il y avait des
critères qui qui étaient comment à
toutes les vénérations aujourd'hui le
CIO a délégué ça à chaque fédération
c'est bien que c'est la question
l'embarrasse un petit peu quand même oui
la question
parce que c'est un sujet nouveau qui
émerge et auquel pour l'instant on n'a
pas de réponse claire à portail mais
c'est déjà important de s'interroger et
de d'essayer de trouver une solution
pour effectivement intégrer les athlètes
transgenres dans les compétitions
internationales ales merci à tous les
quatre merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission et tous les
programmes de Public Sénat sur la
nouvelle plateforme sur internet je me
permets de dire qu'elle est très jolie
comme ça où vous soyez vous pourrez nous
suivre pour notre prochain rendez-vous
de sport etc bientôt
[Musique]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec
l'équipe vous a présenté sport etc